I am announcing that I am committing
twenty thousand dollars towards prizes
at a local DIY skateboarding Jam best
trick contest this is the August 26 12
p.m Martinsburg West Virginia 10th
clocking year anniversary skate park Jam
music games food free parking at the
Raleigh Street skate spot with support
from Mbox skate shop I have not uh
conveyed this to any of the people
involved at all nor have I done anything
to organize anything related to this but
uh I figure putting up twenty thousand
dollars towards a local skate event in
the area will probably help attract a
lot attract a lot of people to the area
we'll help the local businesses with how
many people may end up buying food and
um I'm hoping that by offering twelve
thousand dollars for a first place prize
at a local DIY skate Jam a lot of
skateboarders from all over will show up
and this will be one of the coolest
events we've ever had